can you give us an example of a
disorganized offender professor on yes
probably several andrew cunanan
who killed ultimately ended up killing
Johnny Gianni Versace hard to say he was
actually a spree killer he was not a
serial killer a serial killer will kill
and have time off in between kills a few
weeks a month several months several
years like Andrew Ridgeway the the Green
River serial killer pardon me if I get
the name wrong
those are serial killers andrew cunanan
was a spree killer he had no cooling-off
period he went from site to site to site
killing people he was from San Diego and
Gianni Versace was in Florida and he
killed like ten people in between he
just kept going and going and going now
it may have taken him two or three days
to get change locations but he never
stopped so why was he disorganized what
were some of the things that he left
messy that ultimately got the crime
scenes his suicide I think everything
everything about him was disorganized he
was maybe a thrill seeker I mean I don't
know much about him himself but other
than what I saw in the news as it
happened switch one switch to Richard
Ramirez The Night Stalker
he was messy he would go in and murder
and cut up and maim I heard he took out
eyeballs
put in occult symbols all over the place
not that he was necessarily into that
stuff or not but you know they didn't
try him for that they tried him for
murder and they and he died in prison at
52 I believe so I just found that out
recently yeah but the the point being
that he was disorganized and that he
didn't care where he made his mess who
he made his mess with cleaning up his
mess crossing his tracks we knew where
he came from we knew how he got in and
we knew how he got out access and egress
is the words we would use access getting
in eager
getting out he was just a mess who else
can I think of Kenneth Bianchi and
Andrew Cameron the hillside Stranglers
today they were cousins they were not
again dump sites they would kill them
and then dump them on the on the sides
of the road I think there's the two or
the 134 or something like that somewhere
here in Southern California they just
dumped them just dump their bodies they
didn't care we found traces of carpet
fibers which is one of the things that
led to their downfall
if you will because we're able to as we
said earlier match the carpet fibers to
fibers in their trunk and stuff like
that hair things like that trace
evidence is what we call it so I
consider anybody that leaves anything
not anything behind
but preponderance of stuff behind we
have one of the first principles of
criminalistics is Locard's theory of
transference what you bring in you will
leave a little of you and you will
relieve a little I bring a little of
what you have back we will have this
carpet fiber on our feet when we walk
out it will have stuff from our shoes
and and our skin cells that have shed
hair follicles we will be in this room
not necessarily forever hopefully they
clean eventually just kidding but
there's the it's it's Locard's theory is
the the founding principle of
criminalistics is that there's always a
transference
there's always an exchange so you look
for that exchange and then you look for
the matches
you